Таким Маріуполь був у січні 2022 року.
А таким він став, коли через два місяці почалося повномасштабне вторгнення Росії.
Тепер окупанти зносять напівзруйновані будівлі.
Зокрема багатоповерхівки і Маріупольський драмтеатр, на який скинули дві російські авіабомби.
Лише під його уламками загинуло щонайменше 300 мирних жителів, які ховалися в будівлі від обстрілів РФ.
А загалом, за оцінками української влади, у місті під час облоги та бомбардувань
загинули понад 25 тисяч мешканців.
Таким чином, зносячи будівлі, росіяни знищують докази геноциду десятків тисяч маріупольців,
переконані в мерії міста.
Першочергова причина - це ліквідація будинків, які могли стати фізичним доказом військових злочинів Росії.
Всі такі будинки вже демонтовано.
Маються на увазі будинки, багатоповерхівки, які були спалені "сонцепіками",
по яких вівся окупаційний вогонь з танків, реактивної артилерії,
які підпадали під бомбардування з літаків
і під якими загинуло від 50 до 200 людей у кожному.
Зноситься все вщент, навіть те, що не сильно пошкоджено.
Чому так відбувається? Відбувається так тому, що структури міноборони Росії,
які контролюють будівництво у Маріуполі, для них категорично вигідно,
щоб якомога більше будівель було знесено, щоб якомога більше коштів виписати на будівництво нових.
І для них немає ніякої різниці, чи це архітектурна пам’ятка,
чи це звичайний будинок, для них важливі лише кошти.
За даними інформагенції Associated Press, понад 300 багатоповерхівок
уже знесли або планують зруйнувати найближчими тижнями.
В одній із таких багатоповерхівок жила Інна.
Російський танковий снаряд розірвався саме на місці її квартири.
Цей будинок уже знесли. І тепер наш зноситимуть, нібито ось до січня мають знести будинок.
Я, звичайно, вже потім просто не спала. Кажу: це не може бути.
Я думала чесно, що перше - це якраз кут. А в нашому кутку стояло ліжко, де спала тітка. І вікно.
Господи, я така вдячна зятю, який прийшов і забрав нас.
Я розуміла, що якби на той момент ми там були - нас би вже не було.
Повідомляється, що натомість росіяни збудували щонайменше 14 нових житлових будинків.
Це менше ніж 1% від того, що вони знищили.
Я не знаю, як можна… Як можна зараз?
Пхають цукерку за зруйновані будинки, за вбитих людей.
І вони все одно у це вірять. Я не знаю. Я не розумію.
Вони стоять практично порожні. Вони позиціонують їх для своїх військових, для медиків.
Декому дали, справді квартири дали.
Та, за словами радника міського голови Маріуполя, ці будинки - не для місцевих,
а для громадян Російської Федерації, яких заманюють у місто.
Є важлива тенденція, а точніше це свідома політика, яка втілюється, яка дуже легко прораховується і спостерігається.
Це політика тієї самої денацифікації.
Тобто йде заміщення громадян України в Маріуполі, корінних маріупольців, на громадян Росії.
Без урахування військових на сьогоднішній день громадян Російської Федерації приблизно 37 тисяч осіб.
Це лише чоловіки, з різних регіонів Росії, і середня смуга, далекий Схід, всякий там Татарстан, Бурятія і таке інше.
Тобто економічно-депресивні, з важким кліматом, як завжди.
І вони нікуди не збираються. Вони збираються навесні перевозити сім'ї.
Крім того, окупанти намагаються зачистити всі українські сліди у місті.
Знак "Маріуполь" на в'їзді перефарбували у триколор РФ.
Зафарбували і мурал "Мілана", названий на честь дівчинки, пораненої під час російського обстрілу в 2015 році.
На його місці з'явився ось такий малюнок.
Проспект Миру перейменували на проспект Леніна.
А на центральній площі майже знищеного міста встановили гігантську новорічну ялинку.
Місцеві до цього поставилися неоднозначно.
Новий рік? Ой, не знаю. Напевно, так. Але сумне свято.
Відчувається, що відновлюється, але дуже боляче ходити цим містом, просто нестерпно важко.
Подобається, мені дуже подобається. А вам що, не подобається?
Коли просидів три місяці у підвалі, то, розумієте, якось так відчуття свята немає…
До початку повномасштабного вторгнення у Маріуполі проживало близько 430 тисяч осіб.
Нині, за даними мерії, там живе трохи більше ста тисяч людей.
Більшість маріупольців втекли з міста.
Місцеві живуть практично без опалення, більша частина комунікацій зруйнована, а медична система в колапсі.
Маріуполь насправді знаходиться в такому дисонансі.
Люди, які там знаходяться, це близько 100 тисяч, і вони сьогодні просто намагаються жити.
Вони радіють тому, що просто їх ніхто не намагається вбити.
Знаєте, Росія там спрацювала такою тактикою: вони забрали все, вони створили просто смертельні умови,
це гуманітарна, екологічна, усі катастрофи, які тільки можуть бути.
І потім вони дають людям просто якісь крихти хліба, і люди цьому радіють.
Тобто люди здебільшого, які там живуть, це ті люди, які просто повиходили з підвалів,
і вони вже просто радіють тому, що там сьогодні не ведуться бойові дії.
За оцінками представника мерії Маріуполя Петра Андрющенка,
серед цих ста тисяч 20 відсотків мають проукраїнську позицію і не виїхали з Маріуполя з різних причин.
Це насамперед літні люди, люди, які доглядають за хворими родичами,
бояться не пройти фільтрацію або не хочуть будувати життя в новому місті.
Крім того, виїхати з Маріуполя нині вкрай складно:
навіть якщо пройшов фільтрацію, все одно потрібно дати хабаря, стверджує журналіст з Маріуполя Артем Попов.
Ще 20 відсотків - це так звані "ждуни".
Відсотків 20 - це "ждуни", які чекали "рускій мір", відповідно проросійське населення.
Це відповідна соціальна категорія людей.
Це абсолютно маргіналізоване населення з дуже низьким рівнем освіти
і відсутністю будь-якої громадянської позиції сталої.
Решта 60 відсотків - маріупольці, яким байдуже, при якій владі жити.
Хоча, за словами влади та активістів, більша частина з них після побаченого та пережитого
тепер чекає на повернення України.
Але що буде після деокупації з тими, хто нині підтримує окупаційну владу?
Місто не дуже велике і насправді там залишилися адекватні люди,
які собі роблять в голові замітки, хто чим займається, хто кого підтримує.
І коли туди повернеться Україна, я не буду казати, що там буде якесь полювання на відьом,
але просто ці люди самі, я думаю, повтікають.
Зараз маріупольці живуть в умовах повного інформаційного вакууму та цілодобової російської пропаганди.
З тими людьми потрібно буде працювати ось нам з тобою, медійникам.
Нам знадобиться, як мінімум, декілька років, але ж з ними потрібно працювати,
їм потрібно доносити правду, їм потрібно розповідати про те, що було насправді.
Останніми незалежними журналістами, які повідомляли про ситуацію в блокадному місті,
були репортери Associated Press.
Завдяки їм світ побачив у тому числі й ці страшні кадри.
Ця жінка та її ненароджена дитина загинули.
Її чоловік Іван Калінін досі не може повірити в те, що сталося.
Я щодня засинаю з думкою: хоч би це був сон…
А прокидаюся з усвідомленням того, що це реальність…